forty seconds of logos or waterlogged
Waterloo boat also logos usually take
place before the actual film starts just
in case some other studio buys the
rights and they can stick their own
logos on them later this one burns the
logos right into the movie saying cue
Disney you ain't taking this - in case
you confused it with santorini Arkansas
My Big Fat Greek Tomb Raider and what a
beautiful wedding it's going to be great
to get to know how this family plays
into the rest of the film what's that we
will never see them again after this
earthquake you literally had a wedding
just set up an earthquake well this
movie is off to a shaky start
can we not cut lara croft from the title
of this one they even move the colon so
it now looks like lara croft tomb
Raider's our king named alright follow
Christos when he dives we dive maybe
we'll get lucky and fun disease down
there so treasure hunters are the
equivalent of people driving around mall
parking lots waiting for someone to pull
out so they can steal the perfect
parking spot apparently Angelina kept
her Girl Interrupted speech short enough
at the 99 Oscars because she's showing
off her new jetski hard court instead of
you know getting to work on what appears
to be a time sensitive matter exam two
collected treasures from all over the
world he stoled them in two places
action movie avoids usual trope of
starting with a big action set piece by
taking a huge expositional dump on a
boat this is not better even half the
temple is intact it will still be the
greatest find since the pyramids wait
where the pyramids ever lost how does
one lose a pyramid yeah be sent to his
hair bars look at the currents along the
shelf now did I put in the wrong blu-ray
this is a seismic oceanography class you
do eventually have rating in your Tomb
Raider movie don't you so while they're
all diving net
the ruins will actually be here this
information about the current seems
simple obvious and public there is no
legitimate reason that every other
Raider would have missed this except the
ones from Auckland
another full ten seconds wasted just
watching a freaking boat start to move
across the water we're literally six
minutes in and I'm not sure if the
actual movie has begun the shark jump
scare is unnecessary ineffective and
like everything else in this godforsaken
jumble pudding of an opening a complete
waste of our time sure she uses the
shark later like he's on call or some
this movie anyway sheesh Laura plunges
through this coral with the ecological
sensitivity of daniel plainview raiders
got a raid I guess I feel like I'm
beating a dead shark here but why is
this movie killing so much time they
literally slow down this pan over to
reveal Laura entering the ripples in the
water give it away why do you hate me
movie here's ten cents so that you know
what you did this is huge and
surprisingly not filled with a lot of
water mind you the structure has a roof
but it's clearly leaking and the
earthquake happened at least a couple
days ago
as she's talking about you know you
thankfully they kept told a sharp
dialogue and witty banter from the first
film intact
how does she always know if she sticks
the pony thing in the thingamabob she
will find exactly what she's looking for
does every tomb in the series come
equipped with perfectly spaced ledges
for one to jump up on to find treasure
at the end of the day Laura is pretty
much just a show-off
right I mean in what way are these
spread-eagle somersaults a better way to
get across these beams than you know
just scooting across so this is why they
called it Tomb Raider Creed on my balls
wait did I read that wrong Laura leaves
her gun and the most convenient place
possible incase killers show up and she
has to hide out this exact waterhole
forgetting how bullets would even leave
the water that fast how is she aiming
through turbulent ocean water tell me
honestly now if I showed you the scene
of temple destruction would you be able
to distinguish this between The Mummy
The DaVinci Code or national treasure
sure taking out your adversaries way of
escape is as obvious as nipples in a
wetsuit but aren't Aysen Gary's vehicles
still around here somewhere come on
we'll be at least attempt some
continuity with this Cup she cuts her
arm here then swims with both arms and
no blood here and here and then clearly
shows no blood or cuts on either arm
here but you're going to pretend she was
holding it the whole time waiting for
her moment I've seen rubric and cookie
munching toddlers with chocolate all
over their face tell a more believable
story if jump the shark is the phrase
for that moment something you love
officially loses its greatness we can
now use punch the shark for the moment
that's something that was never good in
the first place officially becomes even
more awful because this movie totally
just punched the sharp Raiders of the
Lost Shark also imagine everything that
has to go right for this plan to work
first the shark attracted by your blood
and wanting to eat you decides to turn
around when you punch it and then swim
by again so you can grab on then it
decides to swim toward the surface
the ocean instead of you know any other
direction finally once it drops you off
at your destination it decides it's done
wanting to eat you and swims away the
shark has effectively better
transportation the most uper drivers a
whole bunch of evil people meet in a
place and one or more of them a murder
because their lack of loyalty cliche
zero seven seven four four six eight one
that is the account at the largest bank
in Bern that's a lot of numbers for them
to remember might want to hand out some
cards or some both to list every orb
ever mentioned in Greek history so wait
Laura didn't even know what that orb was
she just thought it looked cool she just
ignored billions in gold because of some
shiny lights it's amazing how this movie
manages to encapsulate the exact sights
and sounds that enter my brain when
someone says the year 2003 outloud this
happens quite a bit during my bridge
sessions at the sanitarium Laura these
men are from mi6 boss I have checked
both these actors IMDb's and neither one
is set to appear in Mission Impossible
fall out soldier take the box and
transport it to the end of the world it
was there that he found the restaurant
at the end of the universe flat earthers
and parallax Alexander found it using a
map that was with the Box a map he then
hid from the world but the name he gave
this map was Matti and the literal
translation for the word Matty his eye
isn't it also possible he just called
the map map II and was misunderstood and
it's been travelling along with Dora the
Explorer ever since also so glad we're
bringing eyes back into the Tomb Raider
franchise
I'm sure talks of triangles and
planetary alignment is not too far
behind tell me where to find the orbit
last we heard somewhere in China with
Chen lo and the shay-ling finding them
would be next to impossible that will
assign two of our best agents to help
Pandora's box as a threat to the entire
world and the most one a criminal known
to man wants to get his hands on it so
mi6 sends two men to help Laura instead
of the whole goddamn agency and not only
that they don't even help
not in a million years not if you were
the last man on earth will be uses
actual dialogue that has been used
regarding Gerard Butler several times
prior to this film movie misspells
kazakhstan what kind of cheap production
leaves typos at a final product warden
dips here might want to lose the beats
by dre prisoner could come up behind him
with a shank and he would be too busy
listening to his Celine Dion collection
to notice this is simply bad prison
design if you are making your prison
with always this thin you are basically
asking to be grope every time you walk
through convict just happens to be
working out when you come to visit them
Cleese
also why does Sharon have his own excel
on everyone else out there appeared to
be piled in each of theirs with twenty
other prisoners man's prison has some
interesting policies they just lock
Laura in with a criminal sheelane
eleggua scuffed they moved constantly
and they're homeless the most remote
mountain region in China that is a very
specific definition of ghosts
Sheridan must get his info off Wikipedia
so was Laura not concerned about killing
innocent fishermen with her little pod
entrance into Beijing can't even imagine
mi6 would sign off on this strategy
you're close if Croft already had the
hookups in China then why does she need
shared this cellphone somehow works in
the deepest fermius regions of China in
2003 shilling her men whenever he would
from here to lo yang sole artists is
that the shay-ling or not watching the
Great Wall of China and she drives her
motorcycle on it to avoid them but Terry
is riding on the main road for some
reason so I don't understand what the
plan is also why aren't there like a
million tourists walking around you mean
she has free rein to drive on the great
wall and help security or Matt Damon
trying to stop her
I don't expect anything
having a conversation and being able to
hear each other over to motorcycles also
this motorcycle ride is completely
uninteresting but will during ly
unimportant and nonsensical 'edit it
which is perfect for this movie is that
in love of your life just another bump
in the road
skip yeah late I'll never understand why
henchmen are so cruel in public there
was no indication that he wouldn't
cooperate and there are plenty of people
who could be watching also what a
shocker delivery kid is late now tell me
why it matters does he get five less
fist to the face if he's on time you
never know when you could be holding the
shield or tie by the hand as a
mysterious ailment ravages their bodies
this seems pretty elaborate for a movie
villain most just carry around files or
envelopes with pictures in them this
looks like he had one of his henchmen
run down to Office Depot and get one of
their nicer personal calendar packages
he killed him and I would give you all a
bit trust so they did see Laurent area
driving down the road then because
apparently according to Laura they were
going to take the road the shay-ling
we're not watching I mean it's either no
Laura this is a movie information is not
transferred when it makes sense for the
characters but for when it best affects
the audience she take a film class
already that's all you're doing that
requires I could be at least an eighth
of the man she wants this bamboo clearly
completely misses him so how does this
stop him and why does he appear to be in
pain does he suffer from a deep fear of
standing between wooden objects does he
hate the sound of bamboo did he finally
realize how awful the movie he agreed to
be and actually is what the hell is this
movie if Laura didn't see this gun lying
here she needs her Tomb Raider license
revoked immediately did Lord do her
ponytail on the way down
when they jump her hair is free but this
um man clearly has it oh I see perfectly
placed ropes are perfectly placed was a
leonidas with a shirt on would be
excellent at cinemasins luckily just
outside this secret Chinese gangs
mountain hideout there's erode sign that
tells you exactly how far away you are
from Shanghai hey remember these guys if
we can find Daniel Craig we can get the
complete set of two Raider lost
character trading cards doom Raider
movie inadvertently invents Google glass
leaving my men and my country that
didn't actually hurt as much as I saw it
leaving you did totally get this is
supposed to be a sweet moment but really
all Sheridan is saying here is that
leaving a hot woman he gets to have sex
with his heart
why don't you sit down the squared step
having a cellphone conversation and
being able to hear each other under a
helicopter
but I'm not going to tell you any of it
because our best chance is for you to be
completely clueless to what I'm doing
now I guess it makes for an exciting
action scene why did the shay-ling and
rice decide to make this deal in
Shanghai flying a helicopter directly
into the city in a well-lit area why not
oh I don't know anywhere else
helicopter blades survives this well no
one can seem to can shoot her and either
one of these movies so at least someone
is trying a new tactic this whole
sequence amounts to six or seven minutes
of trying to get a box in a helicopter
also they still don't have the fucking
box in the helicopter helicopter in the
air the reddish glow of sunset I swear
this shot is one good CCR song away from
being Hong Kong Skull Island King kids
this is a terrible security system I
have one camera that shows a guy's face
but not any other cameras that show if
there are other people around him it
could sneak in
how does no one see Laura here she is
surrounded on all sides by see-through
glass and it's 2003 Angelina Jolie
that's as noticeable as there's ever
been Terry turns off all the breakers in
this place but the movie tries to tell
us that the robotic arms continued
decoding the orb anyway this Laura comes
with a reloadable cropped crotch gun
sold separately
that's probably something you should
have decided long before arriving at
this moment have you received payments
from all the buyers to control your
using the boys even if rice assumes
Laura is about to be dead why give up
this info and it reveals zero things
that the audience gives it about the
viewer knows rice as a bad guy and wants
to destroy the world blah blah blah or
Jolie in tight shirts and gunplay and
Timmy has never looked around and so
wouldn't the world be a better place
without some of these people as long as
we can start with people that choose to
adapt videogames in the movies Laurens
face looks awfully clean for just having
her head pressed in glass till she
bleeds and then crashing through a glass
window why is this sign in English first
better question why is it even here
pretty sure anyone working here knows
exactly what this is
then go three one-way tickets out of
Hong Kong wait dude construction sites
just have jump suits hanging around
waiting for people that need them this
is starting to feel less like an action
movie and more like a roadblock on the
Amazing Race
rendezvous point is two to half maybe
three mouths
you're a wabbit no one's ever gone
further than one mom and despite this
record never being achieved both of
these assholes do more than twice that
distance and land safely without one
problem by the way why was this the
rendezvous point they were successful in
stealing the orb
then they would have had to find a way
out onto this boat in the middle of the
water it's not docked anywhere so they
made this rendezvous point the most
challenging King asshole thing to reach
ever and if the entire plan relied upon
finding parachutes on the top of the
building and flying over here when I was
the Pope more than one mile away
considering no one had ever broken the
one-mile parachuting record before how
does everyone in the goddamn world know
who Laura Croft is pretty sure she
hasn't had to introduce herself to
anyone in two movies so this rock is the
map well that's what we keep being told
but honestly we've spent over an hour
already chasing down this egg MacGuffin
with extra cheese and we are no closer
to understanding what any of this
actually means or how it works you can
be modest but I'm still gonna kiss you
strange because breaking bones to me
would signify a clear lack of consent is
this a mere max Phelan perchance just
curious
well member thank you young Amanda the
Jolie boner extends across the Pacific
stealing from James Bond and Indiana
Jones might as well throw some MacGyver
in for good measure
also this works also not sure why
videoconferencing is needed at this
point except to remind us once again
that Bryce and Hillary have nothing to
do in this movie how exactly did rice
and his crew make it to Croft Manor
overnight flight time from Hong Kong to
London is approximately 13 hours and 15
minutes and then it's another two hours
to drive to Surrey which is where
Laura's Manor is located so assuming
they somehow got on a plane immediately
after Laura stole the orb it still would
have taken them at least 16 hours and
that's not including all the little
things that would slow you down before
and after a flight duty cast jam on
Honsou but gives him less than 30
minutes of screen time how the fuck did
he know to go inside this house and ask
this family where Laura went
locals call it
there's a tribe that makes a home on it
that might help us could they also help
make this movie interesting I'm going
completely numb and it's my job to pay
attention I mean lower literally landed
yet another parachute onto another
vehicle a few seconds ago and it didn't
even seem worth mentioning this movie is
broken and now so Lamont men are coming
for the box they will open it I'm sorry
if I have to disturb your God's to keep
this from happening this is exactly why
everything bad that happens in these
tumor Eider movies is actually Laura's
fault
in every case the problem will be solved
if she would just stay out of it you
know how to save the world crop go relax
and binge every season two friends on
Netflix so you quit leading the evilest
people in the world to the exact objects
they can do the most damage with you'll
love it there's a cute actress on there
you may have heard of inside you will
find a place of madness this line should
be printed on every DVD case for this
movie know what Laura said cause I
didn't translate don't tell me I'm not
tempted that's a good door into trouble
actually Giovanni Ribisi thirst for
unobtainium is responsible for that I
told them you would rather than lose two
of your closest fan Laura Croft Tomb
Raider Cradle of Life giving your hero
two sidekicks when she actually only
needed none Sheridan has an impeccable
sense of where to land a helicopter also
no one in the villain party saw or heard
Sheridan's helicopter coming in we
interrupt this Ram Boeing to acknowledge
that obvious day for night scenes are
obvious and extremely distracting yeah
I've got over 150 hours between flight
simulation games models and Bryce stayed
in a Holiday Inn Express last night so
there's that this goes on for some time
this guy went to the Prometheus school
of touching things shadow creature
battle formation apparently the resident
evil creatures got bored in between
outings and decided to visit the Tomb
Raider set they seemed to react to
movement hmm where have I heard that
before how does she know how to do this
it'd be one thing if they were a riddle
or a clue or something but with no help
she just decides to drop the ore down
this stump and everything changes legend
tells that when Pandora saw inside the
box she cried a pool of black acid for
tears there are legal narcotics that do
the same thing and you don't have to
fight off shadow creatures to get them
flora allows herself to get choked by
this dude who is not her equal in any
way and should have been kicked into the
asset a long time ago it's the river
that cgz to death the last time we saw a
Pandora's box
Terry was futile II trying to pick it up
using his gun which melted as
it touched the asset now it's safely out
of the asset and nobody did to get it
here we're taking this with us deserves
you're not walking out of here with that
books then what was the point of even
coming here to leave it and hope others
don't find it just to do a little
sightseeing in MC escher cave why are
you even here movie plays the who shot
who game even though we all know Laura's
the one who left I'm sorry but isn't
this technically opening Pandora's box
here this is the equivalent of you can't
just get a little bit pregnant I mean at
least some evil escaped there right why
does Pandora's box sink when it was in
the middle of this pool for thousands of
years the bugs who saved me some things
I'm not meant to be found is it though
because as far as I can tell is exactly
where it was when we started this damn
movie that's a little submerged into
murdery acid but who's to say is I'm
scientists won't figure out the code
that later
[Music]
the wedding day of their daughter it has
been three weeks since my last fish on
my honor or my OB chop double made into
soup y'all ate a wizard is never late
nor is he earning he arrives precisely
when he means
the school cut you from the team
[Music]